kyle is with us in Great Bend Kansas hey
Kyle how are you hey Dave how you doing
better than I deserve what's up
Elton honor to talk to you you too
uh-huh well my wife is doing this
multi-level business thing and then I
just keep dumping money into it and
dumping it I don't think it's going
anywhere and I can't get her to quit
dumping money into it okay I understand
you it's not making money she's spending
money uh yes sir
probably since she started it easily
over a thousand dollars in a couple of
months it's supposed to be building her
stocks she says it's makeup business and
I don't know where to go with it how
much has she sold I think I've seen
probably $20 come back out of it okay so
why is she not selling anything I don't
know she says she's got to build up her
stock more no she doesn't know dropship
to everything have it to her in two days
um and besides that her down lines
probably are up lines probably got a
garage full of it that they'd love to
sell all right um so yeah you're heavily
invested enough into this that you know
aside from the fact that it's your wife
which complicates things all right but
from a business analysis um you know if
this was a sales person working for me I
would say no we're not spending any more
money on this campaign until you
actually sell something and you got us
you know you're going to sell your way
out of this hole and that's a reasonable
response and anybody that knows anything
about multi-level knows that she needs
to be out there selling and recruiting
that she needs to be doing both if she's
going to make it most people don't make
it most people don't make it in business
but most people don't make it in
multi-level as a high fall out ratio a
very high fall out ratio and I don't
want you to end up with a rod full of
stuff when she does quit so she needs to
you know she needs to not quit he's get
out there and make some sales you know
now how to convince her if that's
another thing but um I you know we're
living problem I think I think this is a
discussion like you know let's say that
you were spending all your household
money on hunting gear you know and
you're going yeah well you know I'm
gonna we're going to eat a lot of deer
this winter you know well yeah we need
to kill one son you know because you
don't you're very turn I've spent a
thousand bucks on a rifle here so you
need to you know it's the same kind of
thing isn't what amounts to you don't
have a business that you only put money
in a business that you only put money is
not a business it's a hobby but what
else did yeah so I think the two of you
have got to come to some conclusions the
problem is that you're facing is how
long have you been married three years
okay the problem that you're facing is
is that people's enthusiasm inside of a
multilevel gets so high that sometimes
they suspend good judgment and and some
of these things will actually try to
drive a wedge between a lady and her
husband and go well your husband just
doesn't understand but we got your back
Oh as if as if you're some kind of loser
because you don't get there multi level
hypeeeeee you follow me and you're not
so you've actually got a good head on
your shoulders and you're accurately
saying this I'm not saying the multi
level is completely invalid I'm saying
that she's being hyped and it's blinding
her and she needs to go make some real
sales to prove that this thing is real
and if she can't prove that it's real
she needs to get out of the business if
she can prove that it's real and you
know you let's say she brings in five or
ten thousand dollars well I think you'd
be okay with investing some money and
that business wouldn't you yeah I would
too so if the dad-blamed things where
you'll go prove it but otherwise it's a
bunch of smoke and mirrors and yappin
and that's true of any business that's
true of any business whether it's
multi-level or not I mean let's say she
just took a job with a quote regular
company and they just told her
today how much she was going to sell and
she never sold anything you know how
long before she'd figure that out right
right so it she needs to make some sales
and she needs to recruit some people and
her stock is not her problem that's not
a problem at all she hadn't made any
sales and she hadn't recruited anybody
and if she starts doing that she can
prove that this multi-level is real but
I got to tell you man you're going to
get in but you're going to let her
realize you are on her team and more
than the multi-level upline is on her
team you love her more than they love
her and you know you got to get back in
between them and you not to drive them
away but to keep them from driving you
away okay that makes sense the third
you're running into it you're running
into a lot of emotion aren't you oh yeah
yeah I thought so I thought I could
smell that so that's what I'm saying
again I'm not saying the multi-levels
not good I'm saying she hadn't sold
anything it may or may not be good
that's yet to be proven this particular
one that she's in but but she's not any
good at it yet
and it is not like a stock that's just
complete BS
and that's her up line trying to sell
her some stuff she's the only sell
they're making they need to go make some
sales and some real sales in a
real-world business model if you do that
then you can prove the validity of your
multi-level plan but otherwise it's just
a bunch of crap it's a bunch of hype and
you know you got to decide which it is
and honestly there's some of both going
on here
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below